what about history you know historical
revision is one of the clearest ways
that the education system has been
perverted historical revision and
historical erasure are at the heart in
many ways of the present madness of
toppling all the statues and defacing
George Washington will take this story
just came out May I think on Friday know
Hagia Sophia one of the most beautiful
oldest cathedrals in the world which was
then taken by Muslim invaders and turned
into a mosque and then since 1934 has
been a museum it's in Istanbul which
used to be Constantinople is now
reverting back to a mosque so after
almost a hundred years the Muslim
government in Turkey is taking this
World Heritage Site and turning it back
from a museum into a mosque now all the
coverage is saying it's being converted
back it's going back to what it was and
it feeds into this idea we need to go
back and and give people reparations for
historical wrongs we need to go back and
give the land back to the Indians Nathan
we've got to give Oklahoma back to the
Indians we got to get Mount Rushmore
back to the Indians why stop there with
the Hagia Sophia it's so clear why would
you just stop in in 1453 which is when
the Muslim Ottomans stole the Hagia
Sophia one of the most beautiful
cathedrals why not go back I don't know
for the 916 years before that when that
building was built to be a Christian
Cathedral and stood that way for almost
a millennium
why don't we revert back to that why
don't we revert Istanbul back to
Constantinople because all of these
claims the anti-colonialism the
anti-racism old they only go in one
direction they only seem to be used to
exploit the West and no other
civilization is ever held to those
standards they're simply a tax and we
say they're minor little things oh this
debate over words this debate over one
little site one little piece of
territory who cares when you grant those
little premises
who cares with the mask when you grant
those little premises you grant the left
its entire cultural hegemony
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoice a software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description